la fête internet c'est toute cette
semaine en france si cette nouvelle
technique de communication entre dans
les moeurs assez facilement chez les
jeunes pour les seniors c'est une autre
paire de manches même s'ils s'y mettent
maintenant laurent dit à nicolas le
mariner rendez vous au club des
retraités pour pascal morisod d'aliette
pas de parties de belote aujourd'hui
mais une initiation à internet
elle possède déjà un ordinateur et de
bonnes notions en informatique
même si cela n'a pas été sans mal déjà
j'avais peur le jour j est éliminé de la
can est sorti klein et puis après j'ai
cru qu'il allait fonctionner comment
cerveau après quelques minutes de
navigation sur le web
premier constat moi ma première
impression c'est que j'en ai très envie
mais comme je suis une vieille
génération je veux comprendre ce que je
fais cette recette est souhaité créer un
site pour rendre hommage à son compagnon
un peintre de montmartre récemment
décédé principale difficulté pour elle
comme pour beaucoup de personnes âgées
se représenter vraiment ce qu'est
l'internet tout le réseau jusqu'à où ça
peut aller faire un coup puisque cliquer
de page en page qu'on appuie ans avec la
souris sur quelque chose on puisse aller
vers une autre page france c'est
vraiment à fausser assez abstraite au
salon des seniors les plus de 50 ans un
espace est carrément dédié aux nouvelles
technologies et l'on peut constater que
les constructeurs aussi s'adapte à cette
nouvelle clientèle avec par exemple des
services supplémentaires pour chaque
achat d'une machine
installation à domicile une formation de
deux heures pour la prise en main
d'internet est une extension de garantie
de 3 ans pour les sécuriser
oui par exemple maintenant j'utilise
windows media player
mais certains n'ont pas attendu fille se
sont jetés à l'eau il y à quelques temps
déjà pour faire comme les jeunes qu'il
correspondait en train moi j'ai permet
en est sûr
alors je me suis dit ban j'entre dans le
circuit et effectivement ça m'a fait
retrouver tous les jeunes de ma famille
on connaissait internet comme lien entre
les continents voici donc confirmé
internet comme lien entre les
générations
voici